what comes to mind when you think of the
word excellence i'm sure everybody has
their own meaning for that word
from the dancer to the driver the cook
to the cashier even the pitcher or
paramedic
everyone has his or her definition brian
hobart is a long time las vegas this
writer
journalist and author has wondered the
same thing what is excellence
over the course of his years writing
about and covering sports he came across
the word ex-lead that spawned a whole
new idea all surrounding the word
excellence he launched a new venture
and shares his vision on what he hopes
will be an interesting insightful
encouraging also to help others
seek excellence in everything they do
excellence is it's a culture this
ex-lead idea which was actually a word
said by my former neighbor and i said
have you ever
heard that word before and he said no
and i went and googled and couldn't find
the word
x-sleep anywhere and i thought that's
just such a great word i have to do
something with it
so flash forward about ten years i
finally decided
maybe a podcast is the way to go because
of the popularity of podcasts and i've
always been kind of
fascinated with the excellence of people
and created this magnifying excellence
podcast been fortunate to have some
great guests
already and look forward to many more
ryan found that every person he's talked
to has a different definition for
excellence
i think what's been interesting is in my
golf travels for the most part being a
golf writer and
a writer on some different things i
would always throw in the question
how do you define the word excellence
and the biggest thing that was so
interesting and these are some big-name
people from
you know lebron james to natalie gulbis
to
tiger woods phil mickelson they all kind
of pause and say
and many of them would say wow that's an
interesting good question i've never
been asked that before and they think
about the answer
and as you know being in the business a
lot of the times these athletes or
entertainers or whoever
kind of give a canned answer about what
the game was like well you know
we're taking it one play at a time we're
going to do this do that when they
answer
the definition of excellence they take
the time special care
and really give some interesting
different answers you know marcus allen
the
nfl hall of famer says excellence is a
culture
tiger woods when i asked him most
recently at the match in a press
conference i said tiger
how do you define excellence to him
excellence is winning
and there's so many different answers of
people that it just made it very
interesting and
seeing their reaction i think is what
truly motivated me
to do this podcast colbert has already
landed five of his first ten guests
and he's landing some very interesting
people votes which are greg maddox
his brother mike maddox susan anton bill
walton
and then napoleon mccallum u.s naval
graduate former oakland raider
and he's kind of truly the one final
person that inspired me
when i was wondering should i do this
when everybody's having so many
difficult times should we be talking
about excellence
he just kind of looked at me and said
you know brian any time to talk about
excellence is a great time to talk about
excellence so
you know i decided to do this and
talking to greg maddox he had some great
stories
inspired by a fortune cookie well yeah
there's a few they seem to pop up
anytime
the situation comes up you think of one
i mean there's tons of them
uh probably the one i probably use the
most was
i actually it on a fortune cookie it
said confucius once said
underestimating your opponent could lead
to catastrophe and then the performer
susan anton
just some great stories about uh
spending time with george burns kenny
rogers and i remember
the thrill of seeing sammy davis jr up
on the stage at the sands hotel
i was 16 years old i was able to get in
because i looked older
and he dazzled me and bill walton having
bill walton give me a 16 minute
definition of excellence with something
that i'll never forget and the
interesting thing is he wandered and
talked for 16 minutes about when i asked
him how do you define excellence
but the whole thing was perfectly tied
together because you'll never
learn what you don't want to know so
many of life
lessons it takes talent to get to the
top
takes character to stay there never
measure yourself by what you
haven't done but rather by what you
could have
or should have been able to do those who
are not willing to risk
going too far will never know how far
they can go this is about seeking out
and finding the excellence in the world
because it's out there and i think
hopefully especially during these times
to talk about excellence to be positive
and try to do good things when so many
people are struggling maybe in a small
way
you know we can give back and try to
make the world a little bit better place
if we can
well we're officially launched it's
xsleep.com xlete.com
all the podcasts and news about
excellence is on there we're currently
getting up on all the major podcast
networks but that takes a little bit of
time to get
uploaded and all that kind of stuff but
we're fully live you can listen to them
right now at xsleep.com
all right thank you very much brian we
appreciate that xsleet.com interesting
excellence all right we'll